man show mais annoncée par vladimir
poutine commencera le 30 octobre pour
s'achever le 7 novembre dans la plupart
des régions de la fédération dans la
capitale russe principal foyer de
l'épidémie c'est dès aujourd'hui que les
habitants ne peuvent plus se rendre sur
leur lieu de travail à l'exception du
personnel essentiel les jardins enfants
et les écoles sont fermées sur la même
période ils les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur assure les
cours à distance les restaurants et
cafés ne sont ouverts que pour la vente
à emporter et les livraisons à domicile
les centres commerciaux cinéma celle de
concert et celle de sport sont également
fermées tandis que les théâtres et les
musées ne peuvent être remplies qu'à 50%
de leurs capacités et n'accueillir que
des visiteurs munis d'un code qr par
ailleurs depuis le 25 octobre et
jusqu'au 25 février 2022 les moscovites
âgées de plus de 60 ans ceux souffrant
de maladies chroniques et ceux qui n'ont
pas d'anticorps contre le coc vide
doivent se confiner les entreprises ont
par ailleurs l'obligation de faire
passer en télétravail au moins 30% de
leurs employés non vaccinés en plus
d'encourager la vaccination à
l'intérieur de ses frontières la russie
poursuit ses efforts pour faciliter
l'accès à ces vaccins à l'étranger la
russie cherche à apporter une
contribution réelle à la résolution du
problème ou d'un accès libre et sans
discrimination aux vaccins contre le
comique 19 pour les citoyens de tous les
états nous prônons l'élaboration d'une
procédure de reconnaissance mutuelle des
certificats de vaccination sans laquelle
il est presque impossible d'assurer dans
les conditions actuelles la libre
circulation de citoyens dans les régions
les vaccins russes avancent ils ont été
approuvées dont 70 pays et sont fournis
dont plus de 50 pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à de nombreux partenaires
la région asie pacifique pour le travail
conjoint de localisation de la
production de vaccins nous allons
continuer à fournir des systèmes de test
russes et des agents pour le diagnostic
du coc vides y compris gratuitement le
président russe souhaite qu'une
procédure de reconnaissance mutuelle des
certificats de vaccination soit
prochainement lancés entre la russie et
l'union européenne où le vaccin russe
spoutnik v tarder à être homologué